Welcome to this deep learning lecture.
My name is Vincent, and I'm a research
scientist at Google working on machine
learning and artificial intelligence.
Deep learning is an exciting branch
of machine learning that uses data,
lots of data,
to teach computers how to do things
only humans were capable of before.
Myself, I am very interested in
solving the problem of perception.
Recognizing what's in an image, what
people are saying when they are talking
on their phone, helping robots explore
the world and interact with it.
Deep learning is emerge as a central
tool to solve perception problems
in recent years.
It's the state of the art having
to do with computer vision and
speech recognition.
But there's more.
Increasingly, people are finding
that deep learning is a much better
tool to solve problems like discovering
new medicines, understanding natural
language, understanding documents, and
for example, ranking them for search.
So let's take a look at what
you'll be doing during this class.